welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and why is the incredible hulk so good
at advertising
because he's a giant banner it's a way i
tell him
loki is now past the halfway point of
the season and in this video we're going
to be breaking down
all our fan theories and predictions on
what we think could be happening in the
future
we normally never get these right but
there was that one time we guessed there
were two visions in one division
and i'm telling you i'll never let
anyone forget that now because of this
there might be some spoilers here so if
you don't want anything potentially
ruined then i recommend that you turn
off now
smash the thumbs up button if you think
we're worthy and don't forget to
subscribe for videos like this
each and every day without the way thank
you for clicking this
now let's get into our loki predictions
okay so in episode three we had the big
reveal that the minutemen at the tva
were actually all variants from the
sacred timeline that had been brought
into the center and repurposed as agents
this makes a lot of sense when we look
at the show itself as
if nexus events were really all that
important to prune
then surely loki would have been stamped
out there and then at the start of
episode 1.
instead he was brought into their
offices and enlisted into their ranks
which is likely something that has also
happened with the other variants
i do however feel though that the tva
always goes one step beyond that and
wipes the memory of their agents and the
only reason that they didn't do it to
the god of mischief
is because they wanted to use his mind
in order to catch sylvie
however if you think that's all there is
to it then you'll like wander because
you've
lost your vision and i'm like the
fantastic four reboot
because i've got another thing coming
yes
yes the puns are terrible but but keep
listening now in the comics
we meet several versions of mobius and
learn that there are duplicates of him
that exist in the tva
i believe that going forward we will
learn there's a copy of him operating at
the agency
and seeing this will snap him out of his
servitude
cast your mind back to episode 2 and you
will remember that in ren slayer's
office there were several ring stains
from cups
ren slayer said that he's the person who
always leaves them there
which he seemed a bit confused over we
also learned that she had another agent
in the field
who had picked a pen up for her and i
believe that this is
actually the duplicate of mobius the
fact that she says it's always him who
leaves the stains
is probably because it's always an
alternate version of him
and the shown comics of course have this
idea of copies
laced throughout his character arc now i
think that mobius lungs for his jet ski
because this is in his subconscious
and potentially it's the last thing that
he remembers before he was snatched by
the tva
potentially mobius was meant to die in a
crash involving it
but he could have survived and this
would have created a variant
the tva would have then taken him in and
i would
love it if the series ended with him
riding off into the sunset
surviving the event that he was meant to
die in heck he might have even crashed
it several times
at several different points and this
would have meant that a lot of nexus
versions of him were created
that allowed the tva to have lots of
versions of their best
agent now the tva is too mighty to
escape from
even if you have the universe's most
powerful paperweights
but i do think that they might come into
play in episode 1 it did seem like loki
snatched the time stone
and as we never saw him put it back it
is possible that it is still on him
episode 3 ends with loki and sylvie
almost getting crushed by some falling
rubble but loki manages to stop this
mid-air
potentially using the time stone as a
weapon i first saw this theory brought
up by cosmic wonder
and it does make a lot of sense as it's
not really a power that we've seen him
demonstrate before
now in episode 2 he did make something
levitate towards him during the lady
loki fight
however this ability is something that
he could have used at several points in
the mcu
but didn't which is a bit weird might be
absolutely nothing but poor writing but
if he does have the time stone then it
could potentially allow him and selvi to
escape lamentus 1.
the ark is destroyed and they are
seemingly doomed
but if they can reverse things then they
can survive the cataclysm
there's also a theory from tito caston
on twitter that i think could hold a lot
of weight
potentially the majority of the episode
is actually an illusion
all being played out by sylvie in order
to learn more about loki
in the latest entry we open with lady
loki and sasha lane's character
c20 in a bar this is revealed to be
faker than my wife's love for the mcu
when i'm forcing her to watch another
marathon of them for the fifth time this
year
and the scene itself was somewhat
repeated on the train
in both moments sylvie questioned c20
and loki about their life
over a table in a bar in order to learn
more about them
in the episode she even tells loki at
one point that she enchanted someone by
touching their head
and reaching into their mind earlier in
the entry she does this to loki
and it seems to fail but it is possible
that it actually worked
and she's now got him trapped within an
illusion in the trailer we can see the
pairs sitting down at a rock together as
lamentous crumbles around them
and this is possibly her last line of
questioning before she pulls everything
apart
though i think this theory is a bit
unlikely when it comes to characters
that can create simulations
you can never be too trusting of them
and how many times has loki tricked us
as an audience with one of his illusions
i've lost count and you should always
expect the expected with him
and of course lady loki now the show is
clearly pulling from agent of asgard
and this has been shown not only in the
idea of a loki getting a second chance
to prove he's a good guy
but also the aesthetic of an agency and
several of the costume designs
thus looking at this we can probably use
it as a framework
to guess who the real villain is now in
the book we learn that there's actually
an
old loki who's manipulating events so
that the young and rebooted version of
him ends up following in his footsteps
a big shabow comes in the story when we
learn that the all mother of asgard
never planned on letting loki redeem
himself
and that he was always meant to be a
villain it's a major twist that shows
just how little people actually think of
loki
and how he's simply a tool that's well a
bit of a tool
in the mcu we watched as he helped to
form the avengers
and it's clear that his evil ways simply
allowed for bigger and better people to
stand up against him
and fill the roles of the heroes that
they were always meant to be
this is very much the case in agent of
asgard and
ologie reveals that when he learned this
it was
absolutely crushing to him he decided
that if they wanted a villain
then he would give them what they wanted
and became
even more evil than they ever could have
suspected
now in the book this pushes the younger
version of him to take an
alternate path to go on to become
something bigger and better
loki literally becomes his own tool to
improve himself
and it's got this great idea of
self-fulfillment
now this could also happen in the show
but we need someone
namely an o loki to push him along this
path
this is where i think richard e grant
will come in and though it hasn't been
confirmed which character that he's
playing yet
it just seems like perfect casting to
have him play oloki
i mean let's look at the guy on paper
yeah he's an older english man with
black hair and blue eyes
that looks pretty similar to loki
without even applying any makeup
i really hope they bring him in in an
interesting way and who knows he may
even be the head of the tva
controlling it all in the comics we
learn that the character
sylvie lushton aka the enchantress
actually gained her powers from loki
and the one we see in the show may be
more in line with her
there's a brand new tv spot that shows
her being brought in by the tva
as both a child and adult and there are
some little things that we can take from
this
now she likely didn't have her powers
when she was a kid and this would
explain why when she goes to the tva in
episode 3
she's unaware that they won't work
potentially the old loki could have
taken her in
and then given her her gifts and she may
have then learned to use them
he may have called her loki but she
could have changed this to sylvie
to distance herself from him him being
the organization's head
would explain why she hates the name
loki and why she also
wants to take down the tva also her
being a kid when she was brought in
explains why she knows she was adopted
and potentially her parents died just
before this
and then she was raised by someone else
next episode it does look like she's
taken in by the tva as an adult
so they will probably rescue the pair
from lamentis and then we will learn
more about her past this potentially
could involve how she was taken in by
them
turned into an agent like the rest of
the variant and then she decided to
defect
if we get this theory right then i'm
going to change my name to the credible
hulk
and if we get it wrong i'll probably not
mention it ever again
and just say remember that time i got
the double vision theory right yeah
you guys remember i was right now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the theories
so make sure you comment below and let
me know as a thank you for interacting
with the video you'll be entered into a
prize draw on the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the phase three mcu box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the episode which will be
linked on screen right now
huge thank you for getting this trending
yesterday it really means a lot
and if you haven't watched it yet then
what the hell is wrong with you
now without the way thank you for
sitting through the video i've been paul
and i'll see you next time
take care peace